familiares de Mineros esperan ansiosos
información en el exterior de la mina de
oro la esperanza en la región de
Arequipa al sur de Perú allí 27
trabajadores murieron en un incendio
en un total de
48 personas no a la unidad no noche en
donde lamentablemente no hemos perdido a
27 personas no una cifra confirmada por
el gobierno de Perú expresamos nuestras
condolencias a los familiares y al
pueblo de Arequipa por la muerte de los
27 mineros hecho ocurrido en el sector
de yanaquiwa provincia de condesuyos en
Arequipa un cortocircuito habría causado
la tragedia imágenes difundidas en redes
sociales mostraron una gran columna de
humo proveniente de la mina mientras
medios locales indicaron que en el
momento del corto circuito había
personal trabajando a unos 80 metros de
profundidad el sector minero es uno de
los principales pilares de la economía
peruana ya que representa 8,3% del
producto interno bruto el país es el
segundo productor mundial de cobre plata
y zinc y el primer productor de oro de
América Latina este tipo de incidente no
es excepcional en este país en 2020
cuatro mineros quedaron atrapados en el
derrumbe de una mina artesanal también
en la región de Arequipa